>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Anne McLean: I'm Anne McLean
from the Library's Music Division.
We are very excited to be able
to present this special lecture
by Janet Eilber, Artistic Director
of the Martha Graham Center
for Contemporary Dance.
The title is "Cave of the Heart,"
Noguchi's set for the Graham ballet.
It's an interesting and
unusual event for us and kind
of an informal gallery
talk centering
on Isamu Noguchi's
serpent and spider dress.
If you're coming to one
of the Graham Company's performances
this week, and I hope you are,
you'll see the complete
set on stage.
And by the way, if you have a
program, please hang on to them
because they're going fast.
Tonight's lecture is one of four
events focusing on Isamu Noguchi
and our Martha Graham
at the Library festival.
They are made possible
through the generous support
of Dr. Sachiko Kuno
and Dr. Ryuji Ueno.
The profound artistic connection and
lifelong friendship between Graham
and Noguchi is an important
programmatic thread running
through our ten day festival of
events in talks and film screenings
that explore a four
decade collaboration.
Without Isamu Noguchi I could have
done nothing, Graham commented,
saying that he was for her
almost like another dancer.
And she talked about the unspoken
language she shared with him,
a rich vocabulary of symbolism.
Everything he does means
something, she said.
Whatever he did in those sets,
he did as a Zen garden does it,
back to a fundamental
of life of ritual.
Janet Eilber has written about
the challenges of working
with these arresting, evocative
sculptural designs for dancers,
quote, an intimate and complicated
relationship with the sets.
A dancer herself, she's performed
many of the roles originated
by Martha Graham, dancing,
for example,
the role of the pioneering woman in
"Appalachian Spring" on our stage
in the Coolidge Auditorium.
In other arenas she stared in
Bob Fosse's musical "Dancin,"
and in the "American Dance Machine".
Her extensive work as
an actor includes stage,
film and television appearances,
and she has received four Lester
Horton awards for her reconstruction
and performance of seminal
American modern dance.
Since 2005 her brilliant curatorship
of the Graham legacy and her work
as artistic director of the company
has centered on creating new forms
of audience access to
the Graham masterworks.
In this endeavor she's opened
new avenues through technology
and media ventures, like a new app
for mobile phones and a presence
on the Google Cultural Institute,
as well as a substantial
commissioning program
from new works, which
we have benefited from.
I'd like to say that we
are very grateful to Janet,
who's a longtime friend of
the Library, for helping also
to bring the Martha Graham
collection here to the Library
of Congress, and especially
for her collaboration
in developing this festival with us.
We are celebrating together
the 90th anniversary
of the Library's concert
series and the 90th anniversary
of the Martha Graham Dance Company.
So please join me in
welcoming Janet Eilber.
[ Applause ]
>> Janet Eilber: I just
need to squeak through.
[ Applause ]
>> Janet Eilber: Thank you.
Thank you.
And thank you, Anne.
We are so excited about this
festival and especially, of course,
about the commission that I
hope you're all coming to see
at the world-premiere on
Friday and Saturday night
and the many different ways of
looking at the Graham legacy.
It's all a wonderful highlight
of our 90th anniversary season.
Once in a while we say
it's 90 the hard way,
but we're feeling really
good about it.
And we want to say a big
thank you to the Library
for this special festival.
It's really wonderful.
So tonight we're going to focus
on this wonderful collaboration
between Martha Graham and
Isamu Noguchi, and especially
on one particular work,
"Cave of the Heart".
I'm here to speak from the Graham
side of the aisle because I danced
"Cave of the Heart" for many
years as the chorus and it was one
of my very favorite roles.
Tonight I want to begin
to look at talking
about their common
aesthetic, the commonality
between these two artists and the
evolution of their discoveries,
their innovations for the stage
leading up to "Cave of the Heart"
so we can all better appreciate
what all is poured into this work
that they arrived at in 1946, and
then I hope we'll have some time
for questions and perhaps
a social media moment.
We'll hope you'll take some
pictures of the set and Tweet them
or Instagram them, or
whatever you want to do.
So Martha and Noguchi had a
partnership, as Anne said,
that lasted for decades, created
over 20 unique works for the stage.
And though they were working
in different art forms,
they were both searching for the
elemental shape, whether in movement
or in sculpture, that would
provide the viewer with what they
like to say the shock
of recognition,
a phrase that they borrowed from
their friend Buckminster Fuller.
Noguchi said I wanted
something that was irreducible.
And Martha often said I
was after the thing itself.
For Martha that involved creating
a revolutionary new type of dancing
that was borne out of natural
gesture, out of body language,
and while she was doing this,
Noguchi was experimenting
with the same idea,
the power of organic,
primal shapes in his sculptures.
Martha said she was attracted to
Noguchi's ideas because, quote,
He had the astringency that
everything was stripped
to essentials, rather
than being decorative.
Everything he does means something.
It is not abstract, except
if you think of orange juice
as the abstraction of an orange.
And that pretty much
describes her own aesthetics
to a T. I can't tell you how many
times in rehearsal she would stop
and rail against some lovely
new interpretation we had added
by saying it was frankly decorative.
That was the ultimate insult.
Their first work for the
stage came about in 1935.
I'm going to see if I
know how to do this now.
Yes. Earlier in her career Martha
had rejected the traditional stage
décor, which was usually
a painted backdrop.
She considered it to be
distracting and decorative.
And she danced on a bare
stage needing nothing else.
But as her work matured
she wanted the audience
to have more information and she
wanted a sense of place, location
and atmosphere, so she turned
to her friend Isamu Noguchi.
He had created a bust of her several
years earlier, which she hated,
and she insisted that he create
another, but they remained friends.
And he created this set for
the solo she was working
on titled "Frontier."
Noguchi later wrote about this set.
"Frontier" was my first set.
It was, for me, the genesis of
an idea to wed the total void
of theater space to form an action.
A rope running from the two
top corners of the proscenium
to the floor rear center
of the stage,
bisected the three
dimensional void of stage space.
This seemed to throw the
entire volume of air straight
out over the heads of the audience.
At the rear convergence there
was a small section of log fence
to start from and return to.
The white ropes created a curious
ennobling of an outburst into space,
and at the same time, of the
public's inrush towards infinity.
Martha had suggested to him
that she wanted something
like the railroad tracks.
Her family traveled
across country quite often,
and that idea of perspective.
Noguchi finished, This set
was the point of departure
for all my subsequent theater work.
Space became a volume to
be dealt with sculpturally.
Prior to "Frontier" in 1935 --
there's one with Martha
next to the set --
Martha had already been
experimenting with this idea
of the power of manipulating
the empty space on stage
with her choreography for
large groups of women.
"Heretic," from 1929, is a prime
example of Martha's use of space
to support her emotional
theme, with its wall of women
in black constantly shifting
and blocking the path,
blocking the freedom of
the lone figure in white.
It was a modernist, geometric
evocation of oppression.
In her classics "Primitive
Mysteries" from 1931,
"Celebration" from '34,
and "Panorama" from 1935,
which had a cast of 33 dancers,
Martha was mining the space on stage
with her geometric patterns,
the counterpoint of these groups
of women, to create pathways,
tableaus, lines of force
and different levels
to most powerfully send her
message, her emotional message.
In fact, "Panorama" used
ramps and staircases on stage,
as well as an overhead
mobile by Alexander Calder.
So she was primed with these ideas
when she and Noguchi connected,
and the two of them continued to
innovate and develop this idea.
You'll see "Appalachian Spring"
in our programs this weekend,
and I'm going to show
you a little bit of it.
The stage here at the Library
is concise, so we do --
part of the set is kind of through
the door in the back of the stage,
but that's the way
Martha must have done it
in the very first performance,
but I want to show you a film
that shows you the entire set and
you'll see that it's an extension
of the discoveries Noguchi
talked about in "Frontier".
The beams of this house, this
outline of a house that is on stage,
have that same idea of
perspective built into them
so that space is pushed out
over the audience's head,
and at the same time inviting them
in to this new home
nestled in the prairie.
Let me see if I can manage this.
Come on. There it is.
This is kind of a side
view at the moment.
The camera's going to come around
and give you the front
and center view.
[ Music ]
You might have caught a
bit of it in that clip,
but you'll definitely see
it in performance this week,
that the dancers are also
required to inhabit this new space
that Noguchi has created.
So as they enter, and in many
places throughout the ballet,
they gesture out across the
limitless space, the frontier,
the future, they gaze
out in that direction.
The pioneering woman is often
making sure that there's no trouble
out there, out on the prairie.
So it's quite a revolutionary
aspect of what Graham
and Noguchi put together.
Now, they no sooner had sort of
conquered this idea of extending
and changing the space on stage,
but they began to understand
that they could also evoke inner
space, the psychological space.
As Martha liked to call
it, the inner landscape.
And while she began
choreographing the mind,
Noguchi was using organic shape
to also evoke the interior.
The same evening as they premiered
"Appalachian Spring" at the Library,
they premiered "Herodiade,"
with a score by Paul Hindemith,
another commission from the Library.
It's kind of a mysterious dance,
even to those of us
who have danced it.
There's no exact narrative.
This may be a woman choosing
between life and death,
it may be a recurring
theme in Graham's work,
the dilemma of the creative artist
fighting against repression,
but it's definitely an
internal battle made visible.
Noguchi said about his set that
"Herodiade" was the most Baroque
and specifically sculptural
of my sets.
Within a woman's private world
and intimate space I was asked
to place a mirror, a
chair and a clothes rack.
Salome dances before her mirror.
What does she see?
Her bones, the potential
skeleton of her body.
The chair is like an extension of
her vertebrae; the clothes rack,
the circumscribed bones
on which is hung her skin.
This is the desecration of
beauty, the consciousness of time.
So the mirror is on
the left side there,
with the swinging moon-shaped
articles,
and Martha in her solos would
advance to it and back away,
really aiming for the bird.
She used to talk about the bird
in the center of the mirror
that was the animating
life that she could dance
to in the middle of this.
So following "Appalachian Spring"
and "Herodiade" in 1944 Graham
and Noguchi did three works
that I consider to be some
of their greatest, all
based on Greek myth.
They both were this was a common
to both of them, very interested
in myth and legend,
and to the archaic,
archaic art of ancient cultures.
I think they understood that these
ancient stories were elemental
to the human condition and very much
aligned with what they were trying
to do in their modernist form.
These three works;
"Errand into the Maze,"
"Cave of the Heart"
and "Night Journey".
Using the classics as inspiration
also gave Martha another advantage.
Again, the audience would
arrive with pre knowledge.
They knew the characters
and she didn't have
to spend any time introducing them.
She could dive right into the drama.
And so not satisfied with just
manipulating space on stage,
Martha was now also beginning
to rearrange time on stage,
choreographing memories,
flashbacks, stream of consciousness.
"Night Journey" from 1947
is probably the best example
of this technique.
It's Martha's version
of the Oedipus story,
and it begins as Sophocles'
play ends,
with Jocasta having discovered
the truth and the curtain goes
up with her holding the rope over
her head and about to end her life.
The ballet takes place, it's
about a 30 minute ballet,
as if her life flashes
before her eyes
in the seconds before
she does herself in.
She remembers Oedipus and
she remembers their marriage
and discovering the
truth, and the ballet ends
with her tightening the rope around
her neck and doing herself in.
For this dance, this
story of incest --
I'm going to have to shoot through.
Sorry, you're going to see
"Errand into the Maze".
Noguchi created a bed, but it's
more than a bed, of course.
He said, I created a bed
as the central sculpture,
a double image of male and female.
So you can see the left side
of the bed is the phallic side,
the male side, and the right side
of the bed has the organic
breasts, if you will.
So his organic shapes, it was as
Noguchi could be so practical,
it was a bed and a story
about incest, but it just has
so many more meanings
in its beautiful shape.
I want to detour just a little while
we're talking about organic shape,
to talk a little bit more
about Martha's interest in this
because one could say, well,
you've got a body on the stage,
that's an organic shape, right.
But really, Martha's technique is a
little more complicated than that.
In the 1920s she was dissatisfied
with dance of the day, which was,
frankly, decorative, escapist, gods
and goddesses from imaginary places,
kings and queens, swans and
flowers, and that sort of thing,
and she really wanted to dance
about real human emotions
and the human condition.
And she started experimenting
with and studying body language,
how we hold ourselves when we are
under stress or when we're in love
or when we laugh or when we cry,
and she discovered her new approach.
One of the things she discovered was
that emotion rides on the breath.
When you're nervous,
oh, it's on your breath.
When you sob, when you
laugh, it's all coming
from the center of your torso.
And through that idea she developed
her famous contraction and release;
the contraction being the coiling
in, the folding of the torso,
[demonstrating], the exhale, and
the release being the inhale,
[demonstrating], and the expansion
that sends energy throughout
the whole body.
I'm going to put on a video
and I'm going to keep talking.
This is an excerpt from a
Martha Graham classroom,
from a technique class, and in a
Graham technique class we spend
about the first 30 minutes of
a 90 minute class on the floor,
sitting on the floor, so that you
articulate and strengthen the torso
without the legs getting involved.
Of course, they are involved, but
and so you'll see in this exercise,
which probably the one you're
about to see would happen
20 minutes into a class.
We've gone through the basic
contractions and releases.
Okay. It's going to
come up, isn't it?
Give it a minute.
There we go.
And this one's a little
more complicated.
You'll see the torso
is not only contracting
and releasing, but it's spiraling.
The legs are leveraging
against the floor.
And she began to understand, as
she developed this technique --
and she developed it
on stage, really.
She had a vision for what
she wanted on the stage,
and then began excerpting the
movement that she was putting
on the stage into the classroom
so that she could study it
and teach it to other dancers.
So it's a very dramatic
emotional technique.
And she began to understand how
intimate and emotional, even erotic,
movement driven by the
torso and the pelvis can be.
And at the same time she saw how
much physical power is generated
by using the core muscles, the
weight of the body leveraging
against the earth, rather
than the antigravity goals
of classical ballet.
Quite the opposite.
She wanted both the power
and the message of effort.
These are called pleading
contractions,
and we're encouraged
to think of the Pieta.
We're showing the vulnerability
of the inner wrist and the side
of the neck exposing the jugular.
Release.
Big contraction.
So on our programs this
weekend all of the Graham works
on these programs will
be using this vocabulary
that is entirely driven
by the torso.
It's not always a very obvious
big contraction and release.
Sometimes it's a simple shift
of the back that makes us walk.
There's no such thing as just
sort of a casual Graham walk.
It's the weight of the body
shifting before the foot catches it.
In Medea's dance of vengeance,
her second solo, she begins --
you'll think she's just standing
stock still and then you'll begin
to see her dress vibrate and her
whole body is shaking with fury.
These are all little contractions,
stuff coming from the center
of her body to denote
these emotional things.
They're going to do a
little bit more for us.
There's a beautiful contraction.
They're going to go
into a full another move
from Medea is what we call the knee
vibrations, where her insides are
so stirred up that it gets the leg
involved, but again, it's all coming
from the torso, contracting
and releasing, and the turmoil
in the what she's going through
shows throughout her whole body.
All right.
I'll let them keep going for a
minute, but I want to now talk
about the specifics, specifics
of "Cave of the Heart".
Martha was so eager to
choreograph this story.
In 1941 she wrote a script
titled "Daughter of Colchis,"
about the dance drama she
envisioned, and she wrote,
about Medea, To me, she
is a barbarian princess.
She possesses the animality
of the undisciplined being.
It is bitter, sardonic,
murderess, despairing.
Someplace I read that it might
be any wife to any husband.
I ought to know about that.
She intended to do Medea as the
first commission with the Library
of Congress, and she sent that
script to Aaron Copland who declined
and suggested it might be nice, as
he said, to be a little less severe,
maybe a combination of "Our Town"
and the script that you sent me.
[ Laughter ]
So in 1942 she sent the
script to Carlos Chavez,
but the score that Chavez sent her
did not have what she called the
secret violence that she
had described in the script
and she decided the score
was without stage awareness,
so she didn't use it
until a few years later,
when she created a gorgeous ballet,
"Dark Meadow," from
the Chavez score.
Very ritualistic.
It's known as her Jungian ballet.
And we are doing highlights
from "Dark Meadow"
on our program this weekend.
So finally, in 1945, now we're four
years later, she sent the script
to Samuel Barber who created the
score that you'll hear with "Cave
of the Heart" today, and which
has become a well known standard
orchestral work in the
American concert repertoire.
So "Cave of the Heart"
premiered in 1946.
Martha, of course, stripped the
Greek tragedy down to its essences,
and Noguchi matched her
with the abstract set pieces
that evoke both story
elements as well as some
of the most basic human emotions.
The action in "Cave of the Heart"
is carried by four players only;
the sorceress Medea, who has
been rejected by her lover;
the ambitious Jason,
who's overthrown Medea
to make a political marriage to the
princess; the innocent princess,
Jason's new bride; and the
all-knowing but powerless Chorus,
who warns the audience that a
tale of horror is about to unfold.
Now, about the set.
It's both a landscape
and an inner landscape.
Noguchi said, I constructed
a landscape
like the islands of Greece.
On the horizon, center
rear, lies a volcanic shape
like a black aorta, like a heart.
To this leads steppingstone islands.
This references Jason's
voyage and the Golden Fleece.
Opposite is coiled a green serpent
on whose back rests the
transformational dress of gold.
So these five smaller rocks are the
Greek Islands, the stepping stones.
Of course, they're in a
different place on the stage.
I think one of my video clips
will show you how they're set
up on stage.
And this is the serpent,
Medea's sort of home base,
with the transformational
dress on top.
Martha said, When I needed
a place for Medea on stage,
the heart of her being,
Isamu brought me a snake.
And Noguchi said, Martha
didn't ask me to make a snake.
These are objects that
I make that derive
from a depiction of
an emotional state.
So as Martha choreographed
she integrated this set
into the choreography.
Noguchi's design, of
course, gave her pathways
and gave her different
levels and places to hide.
Each character has a home base.
We have Medea's here with us, and
you'll see when she's on stage,
you're viewing it from the
front and she is so low inside,
it's almost like there's a
lower level to the stage.
It's almost as if she's
below the area.
And she's hiding things
behind the serpent that appear
in the course of the dance.
The chorus, her home base
is the heart, the aorta,
which is not on display,
you'll see in one of the clips.
And the dancers call it the
elephant because it looks
like an elephant lying on its back
with four feet sticking
up in the air.
And the great creativity in how
Martha has designed the choreography
for the chorus and for
the other characters
to use the different
levels and the ins and outs
of the elephant is quite wonderful.
Who else. Jason.
Jason's home base is really
the five Greek Islands
that he strides across on occasion.
At the pinnacle of his male
chauvinistic arrogance he takes the
princess up onto the heart center
stage and puts her on one corner
and straddles two other corners as
absolute the highest point on stage,
which Martha has used specifically
this high and mighty position
to prime us all for the great
fall that is about to happen.
The princess' home base is Jason,
and you'll see why
when you see the show.
They're very complicated lifts.
They're kind of joined at the hip.
She's either on his shoulder or
on his hip or walking up his thigh
or stretched across his lap or --
you know, home base
is Jason for her.
As for how Martha used time in
"Cave of the Heart," she starts
in the middle of the story.
The princess is already there, Jason
has already made the announcement
that -- you know, and Medea's
world is already upside down.
So we start right in
the middle of things.
And it marches fairly
chronologically.
Not so much to like "Night Journey,"
which is memories and going back
and forth, but what she
does do is she freezes time
in "Cave of the Heart".
Three of the characters will go
into a tableau while
another one comes forward
and we see his or her
inner monologue.
It's very kind of cinematic,
I'm ready for my close-up,
they come forward, and
then the group dances again
and then the princess
and Jason come forward.
They each have a moment to
let you into their secrets.
Also, she uses the same technique
in "Appalachian Spring," by the way.
You'll see time freeze, the tableaus
that the dancers make while we
hear the inner workings of one
or another of the characters.
So I want to show you a
video of Jason and look
at the movement motifs for
each one of these characters.
You'll see that they
are very archaic,
almost like coming off
the side of a Greek vase,
particularly the three
other than Medea.
Of course, Medea was Martha's role.
Here's Jason.
Very two-dimensional.
You can see how the
islands [inaudible].
[ Music ]
Yeah. You almost got to see
the aorta in the background.
Next I'm just going to
show you the princess.
You can see how two-dimensional
she is, too.
I hope.
No. It's the wrong one.
You'll get to see that, I promise.
Here she is.
[ Music ]
So she's very frontal, keeping
her shoulders to the audience,
doing all these little
doll-like gestures,
like a little paper doll, really.
And finally, the chorus, if
I'm in the right place now.
This is, in particular, a moment
where she's like a [inaudible].
[ Music ]
Something else to look for in the
role of chorus, which is, I think,
why it was one of my favorite roles,
for the chorus alone
the fourth wall is down.
She's talking to the audience.
The other characters are
interacting, you know,
they're creating something
for Medea to fight against
and move the story along.
But from the very first gesture
of the chorus Martha told me
in Greek theater someone would come
out and bang a staff on the floor
and say a tale of horror
is about to unfold,
if you can't take it,
you should leave now.
And that's the role
of this character.
She empathizes with Medea, but
she knows what's going to happen
and she is constantly moving
forward to the audience sort
of saying you should
leave, you should leave.
And, of course, that costume is so
beautifully graphically designed.
All right.
Let's talk about Medea.
It's Martha's role, of course,
so it's much more flesh and blood
than it is archaic; although you'll
see it does have some stylization
that is within the
vocabulary of the work.
It's her journey, Medea's journey
in the course of the ballet,
so in spite of being
a vengeful murderess,
she's the protagonist of this work.
She has two remarkable solos.
The first one is a lament.
She's trying to win Jason back.
She does gestures,
you know, trying to --
perhaps considering she's
not beautiful anymore.
And this is a solo that
contains a series of upside
down arabesque turns, that I'm going
to show you, that are known now
as the Cave turns because Martha
invented them for this ballet.
She throws her torso over, the
leg comes up, she turns around.
It's a cry, a wail, and
at the same time shows you
that her world is absolutely
upside down.
So here's a little bit,
I hope, of that one.
[ Music ]
And there you got a good shot of
the aorta up there in the back, too.
The second solo is
Medea's dance of vengeance,
probably the best known part
of the music of this score.
It contains a well known moment
where she pulls a long red ribbon
out of her costume and devours it,
spews it out, rolls around in it.
Noguchi said she's dancing
with the snake in her mouth
and then she spews it out
of her mouth like blood.
Martha used to say that it was her
own venom that she was dancing in.
And it's an extraordinary solo that
I'm not going to show you any of.
You have to come see it.
But I am going to give you
a sneak preview of the use
of the brass dress of thorns because
it sits glittering evilly on stage
for the entire ballet, and for
anyone who hasn't seen before,
you may not realize
that it's going to move.
Martha said when I brooded on what
I felt was the insolvable problem
of representing Medea flying to
return to her father, the sun,
Isamu devised a dress for me, worked
from the vibrating brilliant pieces
of bronze wire, that became my
garment and my chariot of flames.
I also think that it becomes
her glittering evil aura
in these last moments.
So I'm just going to show I'm not
going to show you the very end,
but I'll show you a
little bit of it.
[ Music ]
That's all you get.
You got to come back and see more.
Well, that's my story.
I'm happy to take any questions
and anything you'd like to know
about the set or the dance or
what we're bringing this weekend.
Yes.
[ Inaudible comment ]
[ Applause ]
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
Where are
>> Anne McLean: Just a second.
>> Microphone.
>> Janet Eilber: Oh, they
want you to have a microphone.
>> Yes. Where are you?
>> Janet Eilber: Right here.
>> Where are the original 20 sets?
>> Janet Eilber: We
have some of them.
Some have left us, have some
private owners at this point.
Do you want to hear the
Hurricane Sandy story?
About almost four years
ago now we moved
into Merce Cunningham's studios
down in the West Village,
which we still are not sorry about,
and about three months later
Hurricane Sandy hit and all
of our sets and costumes,
and many other things,
were down in the basement and
under water for about two weeks
because there was no
electricity to Lower Manhattan
and we couldn't pump it out
and there were, of course,
many other more urgent situations.
So none of the Noguchi
sets were destroyed.
They were damaged.
They need painting and fixing
and that sort of thing.
So we've been working hard.
And, in fact, this is new.
This "Cave of the Heart" on Friday
night will be the first cast
to use the new set.
We've restored the old set,
but we also have created a
new set with the help of FEMA.
And that is really a short
version of the story.
It was quite we didn't miss
any performances and all
of our dancers were fully clothed.
We had over 5,000 costumes
in the basement and --
you know, I mean, a 90 year
legacy, it's like, you know,
sort of a closet that hasn't
been cleaned out in 90 years.
We had a lot of stuff, so.
But we worked with the
Noguchi Foundation and Museum
and to really try to
restore the sets
and understand what
the original was like.
We've had other iterations.
The sets have been in use
constantly over the decades
so they have been replaced before.
And in my opinion, the middle
age version that was created
after I danced in the
company was too shiny
and the colors were too bright
and you know, so we're trying
to get back to the original
looks of the set as best we can.
Only black and white
photos exist, you know,
so you don't know the exact
colors, that sort of thing.
>> Yes. Hi there.
I'm wondering, just seeing her up
close in that last two sections,
what was her ethnicity;
what was Martha's ethnicity?
>> Janet Eilber: That
was not Martha.
Sorry. I should have
>> Oh.
>> Janet Eilber: I
should have told you.
No. This was the cast
>> She looked so Asian so I thought
>> Janet Eilber: She
is definitely Japanese.
>> wait a minute now.
She looked really different
when she was younger.
Okay. Okay.
>> Janet Eilber: This
was a cast from the '80s.
>> Okay.
>> Janet Eilber: Yeah.
Martha stopped dancing "Cave
of the Heart" in the '50s.
>> Okay. Yeah.
Right.
>> Janet Eilber: So we don't
have a film of her dancing
"Cave of the Heart" though.
>> And another quick question
was did Erick Hawkins dance any
of those?
>> Janet Eilber: He
was the original Jason.
>> He was.
>> Janet Eilber: Yeah.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> In terms of the
props and the headpieces
>> Janet Eilber: Yes.
>> that were used in
the various dances,
did Noguchi work on any of those?
>> Janet Eilber: Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Janet Eilber: In fact,
that will let me show you one
of these other pictures,
if I can get back to it.
In "Errand into the Maze," which
I moved through too quickly,
but let me see if I can get
to it now, he created "Errand
into the Maze" is based
on the myth of Theseus.
Ah, and there he is.
And Theseus who went into the maze
to battle the monster Minotaur,
but Martha, of course, sends
a woman on this journey.
And the maze, maybe in her
own mind, the confrontation
with her own fears, Noguchi
created this incredible sort
of cavernous brain space,
those bones on the side making a
very interesting V-shaped portal
for this journey, and he
created this staff bone that goes
across the man's shoulder.
This mask, he created several
different versions of the mask.
This is the one we're
currently using.
But the man, the creature of
fear, dances for the entire dance
with that bone through
his shoulders,
does lifts with the
woman and everything.
It's quite a marvelous contraption.
Yeah. Yes.
>> Well, first, I have to say what
a thrill it is to have you here and
>> Janet Eilber: Oh, thank you.
>> up close and personal.
I've seen you on stage
and it's I'm tingling.
>> Janet Eilber: Oh, good.
>> Thank you so much for being here.
I'm wondering, in the floor
exercises that you showed,
are there positions is there
like a canon, like in ballet
>> Janet Eilber: Yes.
>> you know, first position, and
so that there is a regimented,
you know, that you refer
to, you know, when you say,
you know, position X and Y?
>> Janet Eilber: Yes.
We'll do the position,
the fourth position spiral
on two, four and eight.
>> Oh.
>> Janet Eilber: We're going
to the back leg extension,
we're going to do the
pleadings with the pretzel.
Yes, it's a codified vocabulary
system that's been compared
with classical ballet
with its methodology
and the specificity of it.
>> Is that
>> Janet Eilber: So we do
about 30 minutes on the floor,
starting with simple breathings, we
call them, just lifting the spine
to upright and then contracting, and
lifting and then we give it we start
to do a spiral and then we
add a head to the spiral
and then we add an arm
and a leg to the spiral,
and then it develops from there.
But, yes, it's very codified.
And, as I said, because
Martha was bringing movements
from her stage works, there are
things that we just say, okay,
now we're going to do Cave turns and
nobody bothers to say, by the way,
these are from "Cave of the
Heart," blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's just the Cave turns, so.
>> Is that in some
form that's accessible
to the public to study or to
>> Janet Eilber: Well, of
course, we teach it at our school.
>> Do you have classes
for the public?
>> Janet Eilber: We do.
>> Oh.
>> Janet Eilber: We
have open classes.
>> Okay.
>> Janet Eilber: And we
have full-time students.
And there have been a couple
of books written about it.
They're out of print, but you
can still find them online.
>> Oh, wonderful.
>> Janet Eilber: And we are
working Anne mentioned our Google
Cultural Institute.
If you go to googleculturalinstitute
/marthagraham, search Martha Graham,
you'll see we have an exhibit
there and it's in three categories.
One is Martha Graham herself, one
is the Martha Graham Dance Company,
and one is the Martha
Graham Technique.
So you can see short films,
a little more explanation
about the language that she created.
And that exhibit is
going to expand so
>> Oh, wonderful.
>> Janet Eilber: But
it's a good start.
>> Thank you.
>> This gentleman here [inaudible].
>> Janet Eilber: Okay.
>> Yes. If you could speak of
the collaboration between Noguchi
and Graham, how the
sculptures were created,
and was it iterative or
did they just appear?
>> Janet Eilber: I'm sorry.
I didn't hear the end.
>> Was it iterative?
>> Janet Eilber: Iterative.
Not really.
Martha would hypnotize her
collaborators, I think.
Speaking as one of them, I know
she would certainly hypnotize
the dancers.
As she was imagining a new world
that she was going to create
for the stage she would bring in
books, she would bring in poetry.
We'd be all warmed up and ready
to go and we'd sit on the floor
for a couple of days
just listening to her,
looking through big art books, and
she was drawing us into the world.
And then she would when I worked
with Martha, she was quite old
so she would not demonstrate
movement for us.
She would ask us to look at these
shapes and create something,
and then she would begin to
manipulate it and shape it,
and invariably make it harder than
anything that we had put together.
And I really think she did the
same thing with her collaborators.
Certainly we know the letters
between Copland and Graham,
she was sending scripts,
they were considering poetry,
primitive painting,
religion, the war.
They were filling themselves
with ideas
and images before they
began to create the work.
And I'm sure with Noguchi
it was the same thing.
They discussed what the theme
would be, what she was going for.
And he would go and create
something and bring it to her,
and if she didn't like it, she would
say, well, let me think about it,
Isamu, and he would know she
didn't like it and take it away
and bring something
else back the next day.
Dakin Hart, who's speaking tomorrow,
speaks from the Noguchi side
of the aisle and he has much
better information than I do
about how Noguchi put it
all together for Martha.
But I think there was this
swimming around in a theme
that all the collaborators did.
Yes.
>> I have two questions.
One is how much does
that dress weigh?
And the other one, we saw
"Dancers World" the other day
and I was wondering what
dance was she preparing for.
And then that thing that
she puts in her hair
>> Janet Eilber: Yeah.
>> and then the brooch, was
that Noguchi or was that her?
>> Janet Eilber: Totally Noguchi.
Aren't they beautiful?
That was "Night Journey".
She was preparing herself
as Jocasta.
And that is just a
beautiful headdress
for the queen, a very unusual crown.
The brooch, at the end of the
ballet, she's lying upside
down in the bed and Oedipus walks
on top of the bed and leans over
and grabs the brooch off her costume
and stabs out his eyes.
>> Ooh.
>> Janet Eilber: Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Janet Eilber: It's
remarkable, you know.
>> And how much does
the dress weigh?
I'm sorry.
>> Janet Eilber: Oh, you know,
that little woman who was carry it
around is five foot tall,
so it's not that much.
>> Very light?
>> Janet Eilber: Yeah.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> I guess my question was
answered because I was thinking
about that headdress, too.
>> Janet Eilber: Yes,
the Jocasta headdress.
>> But was this done for
Martha's height, this
>> Janet Eilber: Yes.
Good question.
Because I've danced Jocasta
and the bed's a little
short for me, you know.
The brass dress has
not changed size.
Occasionally we've made a
longer bench for a taller dancer
for "Deep Song" or something,
but the Noguchi sets
remain the same size.
But if you I shouldn't
tell you this, but PeiJu,
our beautiful Chinese dancer
who's dancing Medea this weekend,
has to go down into the serpent
and take the crown for the princess
and crawl out between
the snake right here.
She has to crawl out of here.
And she doesn't get to use her
hands because she's got the crown.
So she does it beautifully, but
for her to get up on one knee
and get her hand underneath
there, you'll be impressed.
I'm going to knock on
wood I haven't jinxed her.
Great. One more.
>> I'm interested in the
spider title to the dress also.
And then my other question
is how the program was chosen
for the performances this weekend,
and particularly what might
we see in the Lidberg.
>> Janet Eilber: Ah, yes.
What was the first
part of that question?
>> Spider.
>> Janet Eilber: Spider.
You know, I don't know.
Dakin might know tomorrow.
I have a feeling it's
kind of like the elephant.
It's a sort of an in house
name that we've labeled them,
but I may be wrong about that.
Yeah. Tomorrow's program,
we were looking
at the best scores
created for Graham.
We wanted to honor the Library's
commissions, which, of course,
include "Appalachian Spring"
and "Dark Meadow," and because
of the Medea script ricocheting
around with those artists,
there's a "Cave of the
Heart" connection also.
And the Lidberg, the new
work, the Library commissioned
with the Irving Fine
family under the condition
that the choreographer would
choose a piece of music composed
by Irving Fine, who was a
contemporary of Copland's.
In fact, was at the premier
of "Appalachian Spring".
So we have some beautiful
mid 20th century music
and that this very 21st
century choreographer has used
to create "Woodlands".
It's a beautiful work.
It's for nine, ten dancers maybe.
It's largely a group work.
He's not given away too many
specifics, but because its title is
"Woodlands," when I see it --
and it's a very complex,
geometric, flowing work.
I think it has to do with
being in the woods, you know,
but in every permutation
of that idea,
both psychologically and physically.
It's really quite a lovely
caper, I have to say.
[ Inaudible comment ]
>> Janet Eilber: Microphone,
microphone.
>> In the first little segment
you showed us of Martha dancing
in the costume, she does these
little she lifts both legs,
and that seems to be
something she does a lot.
Is there something she a meaning
for her about the little hops?
>> Janet Eilber: Little hops.
>> You know, the
>> Janet Eilber: In the "Cave
of the Heart" Medea one, or
>> The one where she's in
the beautiful red gown.
I guess that's the Medea character.
And she's posing like that
and she jumps up twice.
She lifts both legs up.
>> Janet Eilber: Oh, oh.
I know what you mean.
The chorus.
No, that's my role.
That's not Martha.
Yeah. She does these very
flatfooted jumps on occasion.
And again, as the antithesis of
that light, airy, pointed foot leap
that a ballet dancer would do.
It's more stamping her foot,
yeah, especially for that the role
of the chorus, where
she's trying not
to tell you anything
emphatically, boom, boom.
Yep. Yeah.
Did we do it?
Great. Thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
Hope you come see the show.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.